Yeah,
I would say the most fascinating part
about saving that really motivates most
people and in particular young people,
is this whole notion of compound growth.
Now,
you know,
we all learned this in our,
in our math classes,
but what happens is,
is we save a little money and then it
earns interest or return.
Then our interests in our,
in the mount we saved starts to grow
itself and it just keeps snowballing.
In fact,
I'll give you a little,
um,
a little like sample,
which is unrealistic,
but it really shows compound growth.
If you,
if you had a penny and it doubled every
day for 30 days,
that penny would grow to over $10
million.
Now certainly we have our money doesn't
grow that quickly,
but if you show a young person just
even,
you know,
I'm having an eight to 10% growth rate,
the,
the amount of money that you will have
at a later age,
it's really life changing and very
motivating.
And so the,
I think compound growth is the,
is really the key to that,
which also the other key or motivator is
having options in your life,
being able to do the things that you
otherwise never,
ever could do.
Okay.
Well that again,
that's this whole concept of,
of compound growth that's you know,
earning interest or,
or having growth on your dollar.
Um,
and,
and so what happens is the growth itself
starts to grow and earn income on it,
on it as well.
So it's just,
again,
the snowball effect where it,
it grows and grows and grows really
fast,
similar to how that penny grew.
And so,
um,
saving today,
let's you know,
today allows it to grow from war
tomorrow.
Well,
we try to do is get the word out to as
many young people as possible.
At Schwab we save,
you were in your teens or in your 20s
save 10% of your income for the rest of
your life and you will be financially
secure.
But if you wait until your thirties,
you're going to have to save 15 to 20%
of your income.
And then in your forties we say,
ouch.
You know,
then you're going to,
I mean,
25% of your income,
that's pretty difficult to do.
So the sooner you can start,
the easier is on your pocketbook.
Yeah.